wall street central banks and retail
investors have one thing in common their
growing interest in cryptocurrencies
according to coin shares inflows into
crypto funds and products hit a record
4.5 billion dollars in the first quarter
of this year there's 140 trillion
dollars of u.s wealth
um 400 trillion dollars of global wealth
so we're now up to a one-half half a
percent of global wealth is in crypto
and that's growing i think it'll be a
percent by the end of the year bitcoin
gets the most attention among its crypto
peers but critics of digital currencies
raise concerns about their structure and
their volatility
is not having any income doesn't even
use this doesn't have liquidity services
doesn't have a utility what's the
intrinsic value of it it's just a
self-fulfilling bubble
beyond bitcoin it's the underlying
technology of blockchain that is
attracting investor interest according
to cb insights startups focusing on
blockchain raised about 2.5 billion
dollars in just the first quarter of
this year outpacing the amount raised in
all of 2020. central banks are also
feeling the pressure to create their own
central bank digital currencies a recent
survey by the bank for international
settlements found that 86
of central banks are currently engaged
up from 65 percent in 2017. the
motivation for central banks has been
partly to guard against the risk of
financial exclusion or digital
dollarization if payments shift to
privately controlled alternatives
i do wonder whether at this point
bitcoin should also be thought in part
as a chinese
financial weapon against the us where
it's it is it threatens fiat money but
it especially threatens the uh the u.s
dollar
but how does europe feel about
cryptocurrencies
digitization is now being filled in all
areas of our lives and has already
changed the way we pay
a digital euro would be a symbol of
progress in europe and european
integration
it will be issued as money in electronic
form by the euro system of the ecb and
the national central banks of the euro
area and could be used by individuals
and companies alike
it would not replace cash but complement
it
[Music]
digital euro
[Music]
who knows what the future of banking
will look like one person who might know
is ravi menon who until 2011 was
permanent secretary in the ministry of
trade and industry and now heads the
central bank of a country that is
considered one of the smartest and most
advanced financial centers in the world
singapore manon thank you so much for
your time today thank you it's linda
ravi i want to touch on digital
currencies not too long ago
several bankers would stay clear
of digital currencies but the landscape
has changed i mean we have the likes of
sweden the bahamas china
talking about potentially having their
own digital currency in circulation
what's your view on whether central
banks should be involved in digital
currencies
we
should be involved meaning we need to
keep abreast of the technology uh we
need to
get our hands dirty in actually uh
working with uh the cryptocurrencies and
and
we've gained valuable experience from
project ubin jasper
because we issue the singapore dollar as
a digital currency in the
in the blockchain so i think it's
important for us to be immersed in it
and not stay away from it jesseruben was
a joint project between the canadian
blockchain network corda and the
aquarium network in singapore from a
collaboration between the monetary
authority of singapore and the central
bank of canada it was explored in 2016
whether there could be simpler and more
efficient payment and settlement systems
through the issuance of digital tokens
with the help of central banks in the
first phase a digital token equivalent
of the singapore dollar was issued
this was based on the proof of
concept-based ethereum blockchain the
canadian digital dollar referred to as a
cad coin was developed to understand how
blockchains could be used in real world
payment processing scenarios
phase 2 represented the launch of
software prototypes or interbank
payments
mainly microsoft was tasked with
deploying these prototypes under azure
blockchain the final phase explored ways
to integrate the platform and digital
assets while maintaining the privacy of
market participants jasper uben was a
resounding success it has enabled the
bank of canada and the monetary
authority of singapore to develop a
faster and more cost-effective
cross-border payment system on a trial
basis
then the question becomes
a bit more uh the answers become more
nuanced for what purpose
what is the digital currency supposed to
do
so we make a normal distinction between
a wholesale digital currency and a
retail digital currency the wholesale
digital currency is what you see in
blockchains
where
as with any digital token it does not
necessarily have a life of its own but
it's used to effect the transaction and
so singapore would issue a digital
currency canada would issue additional
currency to effect across border
payments but it doesn't get outside of
the banking system uh what people hold
on to are still traditional fiat
currencies
so
if the problem you're trying to solve is
cross-border payments
you don't need a retail digital currency
a wholesale digital currency would work
just as well so
our leaning is that
for now we don't see a compelling need
for retail digital currencies which
means central banks issue digital
currencies directly to the public
so a digital euro would offer the
efficiency of modern means of payment
and at the same time be secure central
bank money
it will lend itself to areas where
people are reluctant to pay with cash
the protection of privacy should be a
high priority for the euro
in this way it can help maintain trust
in today's payment transactions
it could support the european economy's
transition to digitalization
and actively promote innovation in
retail payments currently the ecb and
the national central banks of the euro
area are examining what the benefits and
risk of a digital euro will be after all
the rise of assets like bitcoin is
bigger than the south sea bubble of the
time or the dutch tulip bubble well you
know our approach with respect to this
kind of assets this is not a
cryptocurrency this is not a currency
this is a crypto crypto asset it's very
clear
this is
this is you know an asset with very weak
fundamentals
uh that is going to be subject to a lot
of volatility
um
i think that when whenever you try to
find out what are you know the kind of
uh
of characteristics of the asset that
you're investing in you know you you run
into difficulties
and that's why you know that's why you
know this is you know i think that you
know the the the the the point that you
know the return of this kind of
cryptocurrencies to assets is not
related to the return of of other assets
and that's why you know uh investors
have to diversify and to to to have you
know a portion of their their
investments you know invested in this
kind of uh
of uh of of crypto assets i think that
it doesn't make much sense in my view
and uh you know that's why you know
you're going to be subject to volatility
you know i think that you know the
situation uh some months ago when you
know the prices were rocketing
um
it's not very difficult different to the
one that we have now uh
when prices are moving down so
when you have difficulties to find out
what are the real fundamentals of you
know an investment then i think that you
know what you are doing is not you know
a real investment but your doing is a
different so wouldn't a digital euro
count as a crypto asset crypto assets
are fundamentally different from central
bank money their prices are often
subject to large fluctuations making
them difficult to use as a constant
means of payment
in addition there is usually no
trustworthy institution behind them
payments are in the state of flux and
central banks have an important role to
play
the basis of the european payment
traffic must be a competitive and
innovative payment market that meets the
needs of consumers and preserves
europe's sovereignty
experts from the ecb and the national
central banks of the euro area have
defined a number of basic requirements
for a digital euro for example it must
be easily accessible robust secure and
efficient so there are a lot of points
to consider when launching a digital
currency so says the former cfo of
goldman sachs martin chavez
[Music]
i still don't know
what form exactly central bank digital
currencies will take
it's not 100 clear at all that they need
to be on a blockchain they
certainly need to be highly distributed
privacy protecting and fault tolerant
there's a geopolitical overlay so we've
seen some sovereigns such as china very
aggressively introducing a digital
currency and you know i i'm not privy to
their conversations but sure i would
love to have international trade priced
in that currency as opposed to dollars
on the other hand everybody's going to
be really skeptical that maybe the
surveillance of another state or
sovereign attaches to someone's use of
the digital current currency and so
privacy protection while achieving
anti-money laundering and know your
client these are all very very difficult
balances but i'll go back to something i
said 10 years ago when i was talking to
one of the early bitcoin ceos and i
think it's related to where you started
the conversation i said 10 years ago i
am highly confident that the fed will
continue the digitization of the us
dollar and one day it will be a
digitally native asset effectively a
cryptocurrency and he said that will
never happen and isilon i don't use
never
i'm sure it will happen and there's this
divide east coast west coast with sort
of a little bit of thinking in silicon
valley that those people in new york and
dc will never figure it out they will
figure it out you can see the
foreshadowing of that i know you were
watching closely during the
congressional deliberations and the
depths of the pandemic and you might
have remembered one version a house
version of the early stimulus bill
directed the federal reserve to create a
digital us dollar and distribute them to
americans and i remember thinking that's
a really great idea maybe i'll just sit
down and code that up over the weekend
but the point is that that that is a
huge huge huge project and there's an
opportunity both for wholesale and
retail to continue modernizing the
payment system we've been electronified
and digitized for a long time your bank
account is an entirely digital construct
the question is do we want it to be
account based do we want it to be like
the paper dollar bills we have except
it's a digital token these are all
topics that are very actively being
debated right now i remember when the
argentine peso was pegged to the dollar
and it was great you could choose at the
atm and it depended on a currency board
doing what they said they were going to
do
to keep that one for one and that's the
challenge with all of these stable coins
and so i think there's a there is a
necessity absolutely for there really to
be a digital dollar
meaning it is a claim
on the united states of america and
simultaneously on the federal reserve
not something that's close to that i
think it is inevitable that we will get
there and i would not
dismiss the power of the sovereign right
go back and and read your political
science right the leviathan uh the
sovereign can demand that you pay your
taxes and the currency that it issues
and that's what breaks the circularity
of fiat currency what if international
trade could all be priced in yuan and
everything exchanged frictionless in in
exchange for digital yuan maybe i would
open up the capital account oh well then
will people actually hold the digital
you on well i'd have to get them really
comfortable on privacy and it can't just
be trust us it would have to be
mathematically cryptographically
guaranteed privacy and so you can be
absolutely sure that these conversations
are happening
marvin chavez raises an important point
here what about the acceptance of a
digital euro
concerns have been raised that central
banks could come into position of
sensitive information about users by
introducing their own digital currency
with privately issued payment
instruments such as stablecoins the risk
of coming into position of sensitive
information is very high
most users and investors are also
concerned that emerging private payment
solutions especially if unregulated
could introduce cyber risks
in the case of a digital euro such risks
could be meditated by central bank
involvement
a global opinion survey on public trust
in monetary institutions payment
features and digital currencies shows
the importance of trust in the
underlying systems
while around 79 of all payments in the
euro area are still cash transactions
the share of these transactions fell
from 41
to 32
between 2017 and 2019
in the netherlands alone young europeans
in particular make extensive use of cash
according to recent ecb surveys but
prefer electronic payments and expect
the corresponding infrastructure to
guarantee security and speed
the covet 19 crisis also led to a shift
in payment habits towards contactless
payments and e-commerce
this shift towards contactless payments
occurred despite the fact that banknotes
do not pose a particularly high risk of
coronavirus infection compared to other
types of surfaces that people come into
contact within their daily lives
during the pandemic the pace of
innovation accelerated and citizens
showed an increasing preference for
digital payments
against this backdrop the governing
council established a high-level task
force in january 2020 to advance work on
digital central bank currencies in the
euro area
so would a digital euro be centrally
managed by the ecb
brian brooks has been part of the
banking system for a long time and
thinks decentralization is key
yeah look i mean what i tried to do in
my last job in the government running
the banking system was to say we're not
fans or enemies of crypto but we do
believe that markets need clarity
and so you know i'm not saying that more
near less scrutiny is a good thing but
having a set of rules would be great i
mean imagine roads with no speed limits
right i mean nobody knows if you should
drive fast or slow and so it's super
dangerous and then you have a speed
limit and everybody knows what the rules
are and they can then adjust their
behavior we need that in crypto prettier
i think the attraction of crypto is more
about decentralization and less about
lawlessness that's again part of our
reputational challenge
for me what we're building here is a
financial system away from central
gatekeepers that's really what it's all
about we're building the internet people
who think what we're trying to do is
build secret magic internet money that
can't be surveilled those guys are
probably in the wrong line of work it's
it's that we're building
decentralized financial systems that
bankers don't control that's got to be a
positive
and what about stability at least if you
look at other markets
stability is often associated with
centralization or at least was a
consequence of it after all the u.s had
a decentralized economy until it has
decided to create a fed to create some
sort of stability
but if we want a system of rules here
such as speed limits isn't that almost
like centralization
we didn't create the fed you know in the
19 teens because decentralization was
bad we created the fed because we didn't
have a technological ability to allow
people to transact directly with each
other and so somebody needed to issue
the dollars that could be accepted
everywhere but we now have technology
that does that it's sort of like you
know the reason that the post office was
the way we transacted information in the
olden days was because there was no way
for somebody in new york to talk to
somebody in in san francisco and then we
had email and we didn't need the post
office the same way that we used to
right so technologies sometimes supplant
the assumptions on which institutions
were built so where you say stability
remain i would say brittleness
yes it was stable it was also super
super controlled right it was also
incredibly expensive and didn't work all
that well it was merely the best thing
we have now we have something better
[Music]
the ecb is the guardian of the euro
whether it is banknotes and coins or a
euro in digital form is relevant
our task is to preserve the value of our
common currency
regardless of its form a digital euro
should ultimately be protected and
regulated by the relevant central bank
an essential part of the euro system's
task is to provide citizens with
risk-free money for their payments
while cash is still the predominant
means of payment new technologies and
increasing consumer demand for immediacy
are changing the way european citizens
pay
this is reflected in the rapid growth of
electronic payments
it has always been through the banking
system
and there was good reason for doing that
because the banks
then create
out of the monetary base create money uh
through their lending activities through
credit through the credit creation
process
if central banks were to be directly
issuing digital currencies to the
general public
uh what do the central banks do with
this money
central banks are not
well not geared up to be the people who
extend credit that's the job of banks so
we need to think that through how that
will work in practice
and then you have to also ask
why why is there a demand for central
banks to issue digital currencies quite
apart from the cross-border settings for
retail and i think um
if there is and this is probably less of
a monetary policy question than a
political one
if people feel they need to have a
digital equivalent of cash with all the
properties of cash the two most
important being anonymity
uh and
finality what do i mean anonymity means
today if i make an interbank transfer to
your account
uh it's confidential
but if the authorities suspect
some wrongdoing
they can actually
lift and look into the transaction and
this is how we detect money laundering
tax evasion and so on because as a
digital trail
there's a transaction record
so
when we go into digital payments
uh you lose that and not absolute
anonymity of cash because if i give you
a suitcase of cash
there's just no way that can be
traced so why do we need central bank
money or a digital euro for households
and companies at all in an increasingly
interconnected and above all digitized
world payment transactions often still
lag behind the pace of the economy
regulations due diligence and different
i.t systems between banks and currency
areas can still take days especially for
foreign transfers this is not only
inefficient but also generates
additional costs bitcoin or facebook's
currency diem intended to fix exactly
this problem however this is not without
risk for users as no one can't guarantee
the stability of the currency as the
high price fluctuations of bitcoin have
made clear a digital euro as a store of
value that is available in unlimited
quantities would therefore not be useful
either advantages would only arise
indirectly if for example transactions
were processed more quickly when buying
online and companies had a more direct
and transparent overview of account
balances and transactions the repeatedly
voiced fear that the ecb wants to take
cash away from people is therefore
groundless the digital revolution
initiated by the ecb would therefore not
initially be noticeable for investors
that takes us to libra we've had
visa mastercard pulling out we've had
the g7 signing a note of caution
where'd you stand on that because
facebook says
that
regulators are
delaying regulation
and that is tantamount to putting a lid
on innovation um we welcome the
innovation i think
facebook's proposal has
generated tremendous amount of
new thinking which i think is essential
for the future
and all that you said earlier on about
the interest that central banks are
showing in digital currencies have been
given a big boost by what facebook has
has done
uh
on the face of it uh
facebook's proposition is that it wants
to make cross-border payments
cheaper faster and better
and it wants to
enhance financial inclusion because it's
far easier to have a facebook account to
have a bank account and facebook can
play that role now again on the face of
it i think those are loaf ft
uh
ambitions and i think they deserve an
answer that the central banking
community and the banking community
needs to work on
it's partly because we've not done too
good a job at this
that you have proposals like this
emerging not that the proposal is bad
but what i'm saying is that it is
pointing to a real gap and and i have
empathy for that to the whole issue of
central bank issue digital currencies uh
is it for purely for payments is it for
anonymity
here i think the argument is about
the dominance of the us dollar
and whether that is
a healthy thing for global financial
stability
because even when two countries trade or
when two people make transactions there
is a dollar leg it gets converted our
exchange rates bilateral exchange rates
are all referenced to the us dollar and
then back
uh to the cross rates so
um
is that a good or a bad thing well that
system has served us pretty well so far
uh going forward i think it's not
unreasonable as as mark uh uh uh seems
to be alluding not unreasonable to ask
if that is the best way forward whether
we should find a more stable
system of of global reserve currencies
again it's all about con it's got
nothing to the united states but say
it's all about the way regulators and
central banks think concentration risk
do we have a concentration risk in the
us dollar
and
what if something went wrong
so do we want something that is a bit
more diversified
i think those are the questions uh libra
poses that because of its proposal to
pack to a basket of currencies
bitcoin or facebook's libra have made
many of the central banks think twice
digital central bank currencies on
blockchain so-called cbdc's have been an
intensively discussed topic since 2018.
many central banks of the world are
already discussing their introduction or
are planning it concretely
so we will soon have a digital euro
but what does that even mean after all
behind the digital euro is neither a
corporation nor a commercial bank but
the european central bank and the ecb's
most important goal is price stability
to put it more simply a loaf of bread
will cost just as much in the future of
the digital euro as it does now with the
mastercard and that is exactly what is
no longer so simple since the emergence
and ever increasing acceptance of
cryptocurrencies such as bitcoin and
co-central banks have no control over
those means of payment
especially their unpredictable increase
or losses in value
the ecb wants to counteract this and
instead introduce a stable digital
currency as a further development of the
classic euro
this would mean that in addition to the
current payment options in cash or by
card we could get a third an electronic
euro that we could use via smartphone
but also offline via data card many
financial experts believe that this is
long overdue because in most
scandinavian countries it is hardly
possible to pay with cash anymore and
the ecb must react to this
the ecb is currently examining the
conditions under which the digital
central bank money could be safely
introduced
in an exclusive interview with bloomberg
ecb chief bakarde repeatedly emphasized
how important it is to guarantee the
security of a digital currency and to
strengthen trust in it conviction
because i'm the president of the
european central bank there is a
governing council that brings together
all the national central bank governors
as well as members of the executive
board
and the decision as to whether or not we
will move with the digital euro will be
taken by that organ the governing
council it will so decide
and that will be mid
21
okay so we in terms of what are the
deliverables now we will soon be
releasing uh the analysis of the 8 000
responses that we got from the
consultation process
that will be communicated to the
european parliament which is one of the
key uh players as well as the commission
and the council with which we operate
not to mention the euro group
and after that mid
21 the governing council on the basis of
that consultation and the preliminary
preliminary work that we're doing
will decide whether we go ahead with
experimenting
and then there will be a second decision
probably you know a year from
i don't know whether it will be a six
months uh first uh assessment or one
year assessment whether we actually
are
going to roll out but the whole process
let's let's you know not be
um let's be realistic about it will in
my view take another four years maybe a
little more but i i would hope that we
can keep it within four years because
it's it's a it's a technical endeavor as
well as a fundamental change because we
need to make sure that
we do it right well we owe it to
the europeans they need to to feel safe
and secure uh they need to know that
they are holding
a central bank um
backed
i would i would say digi it's the
equivalent of a digital banknote with
the same level of security the same
level of of backing as as the central
bank so that needs to be really uh
safe and solid
and we need to make sure that we are not
going to
break any system but to enhance the
system and i'm saying that on purpose
because i know that
uh certain uh intermediaries that we are
using at the moment that are relying on
us as well i mean by that the banks are
a bit concerned about those developments
i don't think they should be concerned
because a central bank is not going to
invent itself
as a
client
manager as a risk assessor for the
granting of credit lines so those
intermediaries will continue to coexist
and to develop their business and to
conduct the activity
with
cash which will also continue to be
available as well as digital currency
but in my mind
if you just observe how people have
behaved during covet 19 the way in which
they've changed the way they buy
uh the way they uh they order the way
they they
you know get their food
the way they pay
it is moving in a digital dimension
which we should not be afraid of and
which should provide as i said safe
solid and secure payment uh mechanism to
europeans and others
so another four years of development
time do we still have this time to
introduce a well thought out and
technically mature digital euro system
the issuance of a digital euro would be
relevant to almost all euro system
activities and would have far reaching
implications for society as a whole
at the same time however
experiments on the practical aspects of
a digital euro are needed to examine the
strength and weaknesses of the various
options
we have heard that many banks fear for
the existence the introduction of a
digital euro could affect the
transmission of money policy and have a
negative impact on financial stability
also in crisis situations when savers
have less confidence in the banking
sector as a whole liquid assets could be
shifted very quickly to the digital euro
thus if withdrawing digital money
becomes easier than withdrawing cash it
could increase the likelihood of severe
bank runs and weaken financial stability
these examples highlight the need for
careful consideration of the design of
the digital euro
in particular considerations should be
given to whether it should be accessible
to households and businesses directly or
indirectly through banks whether it
should be renumerated and whether
individual users digital euro holdings
should be limited or unlimited
for the moment we are keeping our
options open as to whether and when this
should happen
the ecb's task is to safeguard
confidence and money it must ensure that
the euro is fit for the digital age
the ecb commission has described some
scenarios that could lead to the euro
system to issue a digital euro and also
list the requirements that the new form
of money should fulfill
scenario one positive impact on
innovation and autonomy of the eurozone
independence and digitalization of the
european economy can benefit from a
digital form a central bank money made
available to citizens
issuing a digital euro can be a way to
promote the digitalization of the
economy and support the development of
innovative european solutions in all
possible sectors
in such a scenario the issuance of a
digital euro would help preserve
european autonomy in retail payments and
could be a building block for a european
solution for point of sale and online
payments
scenario 2 the role of cash as means of
a payment decreased significantly
european citizens would thus have
difficulty accessing the only means of
payment provided by the public sector
extreme events such as covet 19 may
accelerate the change in payment habits
raising maintenance costs of cash
infrastructures could further drive the
decline in cash availability and
acceptance
a similar trend is likely to result from
the rapid development of e-commerce
scenario 3 a form of money other than
euro dominated central bank money or
electronic money becomes a credible
alternative source of value in the euro
area
private players such as bitcoin or libra
which are outside the supervision of
european financial authorities or big
tech companies that are not euro
dominated which achieve global
penetration and are used for large
payments in the euro area could weaken
monetary policies in the euro area
their influence would also have unclear
implications for cross-border capital
mobility which could ultimately affect
financial stability under these
circumstances the issuance of a digital
euro could support european sovereignty
and stability
scenario 4 the eu decides to proactively
support improvements in the total cost
and environmental footprint of its money
and payment systems the production of
payment instruments and their
infrastructure is not always energy
efficient
a well-designed digital euro can
therefore help reduce the overall cost
and environmental footprint of payment
systems in the euro area
in this context the euro system would
play a catholic role and lead by example
by incentivizing and putting pressure on
payment service providers the following
requirements can be derived from these
four scenarios the digital euro should
be designed in such a way that any
negative effects on monetary policy and
financial stability are mitigated
excessive use of the digital euro as an
investment vehicle and the associated
risk of large relocations should be
avoided
the digital euro should be an efficient
way to achieve the economy and
environmental goals of the eurozone
compared to the alternatives but with
all the visions and ideas don't we see
the biggest challenge in the technical
implementation
how can it be ensured for the end
consumer the supplier or the
entrepreneur that a digital euro is
available at all times and accepted
everywhere
and what role does the time factor play
in this
china is already testing its state-owned
digital currency called yuan
apps are already being used to make
payments in yigeon
even states benefits are partly paid out
in the new digital currency
with the digital yuan china is reacting
to cryptocurrencies such as bitcoin
however china's digital currency only
partially relies on a blockchain
traditional clearing methods are also
used
facebook's libra or now theme was also
intended to give users on platforms such
as whatsapp or instagram the opportunity
to use the digital currency for online
shopping
however facebook met with resistance
worldwide
in politics and among central banks many
saw the project as an attack by the
private company on a state monopoly on
currency and announced strong regulation
of private digital currencies
brian brooks the ceo of violence fears
that without regulations of our monetary
policy we cannot successfully realize
digital currencies
well um my personal view is it depends
on the utility that we're talking about
so remember every cryptocurrency
represents a different function right
these are all different networks being
built for different things so you know
if you're talking about bitcoin which
fundamentally is an investment asset
it's kind of digital gold we like to say
it ought to be regulated if it's
regulated like investment assets are
regulated it's not a security of course
but it's something that people buy and
hold for its value retention properties
versus ethereum is a network for the
remission of payments uh right or for
crowdsourcing of funding and so if it's
like a payment mechanism you'd expect
the banking regulators to uh to talk
about that which is what i did at the
occ so it all depends on what the
underlying activity is like activities
should be regulated alike they shouldn't
be regulated by asset class category if
this is a payment mechanism it ought to
be regulated like a payment mechanism
etc and i think that's the mind shift
that regulators need to achieve here
facebook has significantly modified its
concept of a digital currency in order
to keep the volatility of its prices low
there will initially be only one
so-called stablecoin which represents
one us dollar at a time and whose price
can be controlled dynamically or
automatically facebook has also changed
the name libra is now denim dollar
however an application of approval for
the european union has not yet been
received so why is the eu so hesitant to
introduce a digital currency according
to christian le carde it can only be
done through the interaction of the
market and regulators we have to look at
the privacy issues we have to look at a
lot of
issues that are in a way beyond the
realm of central banks so we need to
collaborate with the other authorities
such as you know ministers of finance
european commission parliaments because
in due course it will touch people's
life
in a very intimate way and what we've
heard from the people is that they want
um
privacy to be protected but at the same
time we need to make sure that it
doesn't it's not accelerating anti-money
laundering or the financing of terrorism
so we have
on on each and every aspect we have to
strike the right balance
and so that will take a couple of years
and in a couple of years when the work
has been completed
the governing council will have to
decide green light red light
there we go or not my suspicion is that
the governing council will be very
supportive to explore for the next two
years and hopefully will commit the
budget to do that because it's not
without some cost but then in two years
time whether it's a
let's go and have a digital euro or not
i think will be will be then uh decisive
well we have um
we tried to to to understand they they
thinking they're rational their
expectations
and clearly you know i don't talk to
markets myself and i i refrain from that
because i think this is this is my my
my duty to stay out of it
but but we do have people who are on the
markets i mean you cannot be a big
purchaser without actually having some
proximity with how markets operate and
what is their thinking what is their
rational what is the expectations
expectations in particular are
critically important so we we have
market surveys
that market participants um
participate in and that that we look at
it's not the only component that we look
at we look at
you know all sorts of of indicators and
and survey
we we are here riveted
and determined by one objective which is
price stability that we have to deliver
for europeans that is the most important
thing
markets obviously play their part and we
have to be attentive to how they think
and what they expect and and how they
see things but our objective is price
stability
the finance ministers of the largest
euro states including germany france
spain and italy have spoken out against
a digital quick fix
a digital currency should not be
introduced until all the associated
risks have also been adequately
considered in legislation
in addition restricting the use of a
digital euro risks compromising
convertibility to other forms of the
euro
changes in interest rates or markets in
which the digital euro is treated as a
parallel currency pose a threat to the
use of the euro as a means of payment in
the economy
that the introduction of a digital
currency can indeed have positive
effects on the stability of a country is
shown by the example of venezuela
the startup value is helping the people
of venezuela in their fight against
hyperinflation
i'm simon chamorro i'm the co-founder
and ceo of value and we're a product
that helps venezuelans living in
hyperinflation protect their money from
losing value receive remittances and pay
locally to buy food and medicines
both businesses and consumers are able
to exchange goods and services with each
other paying in cryptocurrency
the vision for us is to increase
economic freedom
[Music]
venezuela is known for its political and
economic instability
hyperinflation has caused the bolivar to
lose 99.9 percent of its value in just
two years
wealthy venezuelan families saw their
fortunes disappear and the poor were
pushed even further into desperation
simon shomero knows this story all too
well
growing up in venezuela essentially
whatever my dad and my mom were able to
build
during their life was lost
when the economy started to fail we for
example had water shortages or like
electricity blackouts across the country
money was starting to get hyperinflated
this is not like a sad story that i'm
trying to tell this is the reality of
most venezuelans more than 99 of the
venezuelans lost everything they've
built because the country failed
all of the venezuelans savings of
most middle class people went to zero
i knew i wanted to build something i had
to find my purpose i always knew i
wanted to start a company and to build
things which is the reason why i studied
industrial design with the hypothesis
that i was going to be able to build
things i didn't pursue that career but i
learned a lot of things that got me into
tech so i found crypto through tech i
felt passionate about the technology and
then when i understood the potential of
crypto i realized that venezuela is
potentially the best place to do this at
a massive scale
the reality is if we deconstruct
cryptocurrencies the base most basic
thing is that it helps disintermediate
and this may have the possibility to
change society as we know it
the main problem venezuela's are going
through right now is hyperinflation
hyperinflation is just a byproduct of
total mismanagement of the country
venezuela's descent into an impoverished
dictatorship
put the devastating effects of
hyperinflation on full display for the
world to see
lines for basic needs extreme shortages
of food and medical supplies civil
strife
violence
and the citizens spared were the ones
who could move their currency out of
venezuela to other more stable
currencies like the us dollar a luxury
mostly saved for the ultra elite
but simon's platform value promises the
opportunity for everyday venezuelans to
protect themselves from hyperinflation
by way of cryptocurrency
and according to him the unstable
conditions of his country are the
perfect breeding ground for such an
experiment
nobody trusts the currency or the
government
people are looking for solutions in a
place where people are trying to survive
the barrier of trying new things is much
lower so diesel dollars stable coins
cryptocurrencies people are going to be
willing to try it with a little bit of
money and then slowly kind of get there
our main objective right now as a
company is to enable merchants to accept
digital dollars as a minimum of payment
and so people have to use the
bolivar less and less
we're focused on building a product that
serves from the richest person with a
lot of education and technical literacy
from the lowest income person with very
low education and low technical literacy
in a country like venezuela where the
minimum wage is one dollar
you have a situation where most people
are starting their own little business
selling hot dogs or selling the local
food called aleppas or whatever they do
but they sell it to their community
and you have these hyper local
communities so we want to help them
accept payments in dollars in digital
dollars stablecoins and then onboard
users
the more consumers that paying dollars
the better for the merchants the more
merchants that accept it the better for
the consumer
[Music]
so far we've moved millions of dollars
we've helped more about 150 000
households 30 000 monthly active users
and is working
the reality is is that economic freedom
it's only directly tackled by the
innovation that is cryptocurrencies
but we can't forget that venezuela has
tried this already el petro was a
proposed cryptocurrency backed by the
country's most abundant resource
oil
while el petro was widely considered a
resounding failure many experts agree
that the experiment was a necessary step
in establishing cryptocurrency for the
future and simon is convinced that its
foundations namely blockchain technology
remain stronger than ever and ready for
another more practical iteration
blockchain is really a paradigm shift
for the human race it's one of the most
important things that has happened in
recent history
what you're starting to see
is
companies
starting to completely build their
products on top of this
blockchain it's almost like it's
creating its own economy
if there's a way to provide more
stability and economic freedom and
financial freedom to venezuelans without
crypto
i would rather for that to happen than
for me to be successful with a product
that doesn't bring value to to the
people
venezuela's hyperinflation shows that
the country's monetary policy does not
always function according to the
international rules of the game
our expectations that the monetary
policy of a central bank can't save us
at any time should our money get into
trouble must therefore be questioned in
the future when even an oil-rich country
like venezuela can get into
hyperinflation one who has been
questioning this quantitative async and
money policy for some time is rev on
i think that is wrong and i think it's
also wrong for central banks to feed
that
expectation
um
monetary policy provides the basis for
sustained non-inflationary economic
growth it provides
stability predictability over the medium
term then the value of money will be
will be stable
and that is the basis for then carrying
out economic activities
but it can't be that every slowdown
every uh
risk or threat on the horizon has to be
addressed by a loosening of monetary
policy
i think fiscal policy has a strong role
to play
and that has not been sufficiently
addressed
partly because too much of the weight
has been placed in monetary policy so i
think we need a better balance between
the two
otherwise it is
exceedingly unfair on the central
banking community singapore wouldn't
need qe
because our monetary policy is based on
the exchange rate
managing the exchange rate so we're not
subject to the zero lower bound of
interest rates
and even that they think of negative
interest rates and qe as supplements
with an exchange rate centered monetary
policy those considerations don't apply
we can if necessary
bring the exchange rate path to to to
zero as we've done before
uh we've never before
uh uh had a policy of deliberately
depreciating the currency
um
but we can re-center the exchange rate
downwards which we've done before too if
we think the current rate of the
exchange rate is too tight uh we can
always recenter the band downwards
and
with that flexibility there is actually
no constraint
so we have a fair amount of policy space
on on the monetary front without having
to think about qe
so while the ecb is currently still
working on a concept for the digital
euro central banks in other countries
are usually already one step ahead in
2018 the top banking institution of the
federal republic of germany the german
bundesbank also announced that it was
actively working on a blockchain-based
solution
headquartered in frankfurt and maine the
institution manages around 200 billion
euros in government reserves and is part
of the european system of central banks
according to its own statements the bank
is now intensifying its research in the
field of distributing ledger technology
and has already named a corresponding
partner
ocean protocol is to support the dutch
vanderspunk in his further plans with
this technology
founded in singapore in 2017 made in
highland develops innovative apps for
the coming data economy and connects
data providers and users using
blockchain technology oceans enable data
owners to monetize data while retaining
control over their data assets the dutch
sponsorsmonk is therefore launching its
own blockchain project the focus of this
collaboration is on a decentralized
network that allows users permanent
symmetrical access to data
this should for example enable real-time
updates of statistics while maintaining
data sovereignty according to the
bundesbank
ocean protocol was the only company able
to offer a technical solution for our
project that is already
operational
in addition a platform for the secure
storage transfer and use of public and
private data is to be developed
it remains open whether the singapore
company is also involved in research
into a digital euro
but what about german companies how do
they generally feel about the
introduction and usability of a digital
euro
78
that is three quarters of all companies
with 50 or more employees are in favor
of introducing a digital euro
only one in five companies 20 percent
consider these plans to be unsuccessful
this is the result of a recent survey of
652 companies from all sectors in
germany in 2021
above all the possibility that other
private digital currencies might
otherwise come into use which could
undermine european values speaks in
favor of a digital euro from the
company's point of view
69 of companies see the need for
tokenized securities to enable seamless
payments and settlement processes in the
capital market almost as many namely 64
percent
think that it is advantageous to have a
digital euro should the importance of
cash decline
in this way citizens would continue to
have direct access to the central bank
in the digital age that a digital euro
would enable the ecb to implement
innovative monetary policy instruments
more effectively in times of crises is
believed by 60 of respondents
around 40 percent would like to
increasingly automate payment process
and see the need for a programmable euro
in industry here
the keyword here is m2m payment i
machined two machine payments on the
internet
only 11 believe that a digital euro
would have no advantages at all
alongside the advocates of the digital
age however there are also skeptics
about the introduction of a digital euro
65 or around two-thirds see data
protection risk here if the central bank
were to gain deeper insights into our
payment processes
around one in two companies also see
this as a threat to financial stability
after all issuing the digital euro could
reduce the influence of banks in times
of crisis
but only three percent of banks and
financial service providers think
nothing of the ecb issuing a digital
euro around eight percent of the economy
as a whole believe that the economy
should develop its own solutions for the
payment transactions of the future
13 say there is nothing to be said
against a digital euro
thus 35 of the banking and financial
business are in favor of the
introduction of a digital euro in
assessment of the tendency 46 would
rather agree to a digital euro and only
9 clearly says no in any case the ecb is
determined to introduce a digital euro
the so-called euro this is to be issued
in parallel to cash which is
expressively not to be abolished
this is the ecb's response to numerous
new forms of payment such as crypto
assets like bitcoin liam or china's
euron
ecb president lagarde expects the euro
to be in the virtual wallets of eurozone
consumers in as little as four years and
then to be in heavy use
china is far ahead in the development of
a digital currency and sweden's central
bank is also working on the digital
corner what the euro will look like in
the end is not yet known not even by the
monetary guardians
but this much is already clear the
digital euro will be issued and
controlled by the ecb just like cash
like coins bills or book money in
checking or saving accounts it will be
created by the ecb and commercial banks
unlike bitcoin and other crypto assets
the central bank thus retains control
over the currency which is intended to
guarantee the stability and security of
the digital euro
the euro is to be stored in the kind of
virtual wallet and move into the
seller's virtual cache registered by
means of simple procedure for example
through an app or a qr code
this will be possible online via the
internet for example as well as offline
via bluetooth
in the future it will be much easier and
faster to make a payment than before via
scpa bank transfer
the whole thing will work via separate
account a direct account with the ecb so
to speak but still managed by the
commercial banks thus the euro is still
protected by the ecb even if private
financial institutions get into
difficulties due to a crises
privacy is also increasingly assured
because unlike major u.s credit card
companies no personal data is
transmitted during the transaction
on july 14th the council of the european
central bank decided to launch the
digital euro project
a lot of analysis have been done
feedback from citizens as well as
experts have been gathered
and the practical trial has been
conducted
with encouraging results
all of this has made it possible to
launch the digital euro project and who
knows maybe in four years we will be
shopping with the digital euro as
naturally as we do with credit card or
debit cards
the ecb and the euro area are well on
their way to bringing our financial
system into the digital age in a
controlled and secure manner
the digital euro will be the next step
into the future for europe and its
citizens
[Music]
you